hi guys Lucy here with some more
gamespot news is just for you after 4.6
million of us are still riding that
sweet mmm oh hi from the destiny beta
Bungie have started teasing us with
information about their endgame content
and while we've had a taste of the story
and strike missions and dipped our toes
into the pool of competitive multiplayer
what a high level players going to do
once they complete the story well
luckily Bungie has big plans for its end
game and these include MMO style raids
the events will be challenging and
you'll need to strategize and cooperate
to complete them but if you do you'll be
greatly rewarded in fact they're so
difficult that Bungie isn't even
building matchmaking into these six
player raids speaking to IGN bungees
Luke Smith explained that the developer
wants players to form teams that have a
strong desire to work together it's
hoping to accomplish this by taking the
dangerous step of forcing players to
team up with friends without matchmaking
now that sounds like a whole load of
organization and planning to me but
Bungie thinks the payoff from working as
a team and getting some sweet delicious
gear will keep players coming back and
while Bungie isn't detailing exactly
what the raids will entail just yet they
promise that they'll be unique we don't
adhere to any of the standard rules for
the rest of the game like raids don't
have waypoints they don't tell you where
to go they don't tell you what to do
Bungie also revealed that the enemies
will have a bunch of abilities the likes
of which we've never experienced in a
shooter before are you excited to get
stuck into Destiny's raid did that
Wizard really come from the moon let me
know in the comments for all the latest
stay tuned here to gamespot
you